Russian President Vladimir Putin
making his first visit
to occupied Ukraine since the war began.
I look,
this is video of him
driving through the city of Mariupol,
which Russia occupied last year.
The city suffered
heavy damage and fighting
and became the symbol of Ukraine's
resistance to Moscow's aggression.
The Kremlin says Putin
also stopped in their neighborhood
and spoke to residents.
They say he was invited
into one of their homes
early on Saturday.
Putin flew to Crimea
to mark
the ninth anniversary
since Russia announced the annexation
of the Ukrainian peninsula.
The move was made after
Russia sent in troops
and staged a hasty referendum in 2014.
Ukraine says
Crimea has been suffering under
Kremlin rule.
He also said
it's only a matter of time
before all of its occupied
lands are liberated.
CNN's Clare Sebastian
joins us now from London with more.
So Clare, what message
is Putin trying to send here?
What can these visits for
unannounced and come just a day
of course
after an arrest warrant was issued
by the International Criminal Court
against Vladimir Putin himself.
Obviously with Crimea,
it was designed
to coincide with the anniversary
of that annexation,
the ninth anniversary.
But visiting Mariupol, which we believe
is the first time
he's visited Russian
occupied territories in Ukraine
since the invasion began.
At that may be read
as an act of defiance, a low risk one.
It should be noted,
given that this is Russian occupied
territory, but still,
you know,
thumbing his nose potentially
at that arrest warrant
in terms of the Russian people
and how this is being presented to them.
Look,
I mean, he's seen behind the car
they're driving from the airport
in Mariupol towards Mariupol.
We believe
the last time we saw him buying
the car was driving
behind the wheel of a car,
was driving a truck
across the Kutch Bridge to Crimea
that was blown up in the autumn
and then partially rebuilt by Russia.
It's designed to protect project control
that he's in charge.
I think there's also an element
of normalizing
these territories as part of Russia.
He's there with the deputy prime minister
Nuland discussing reconstruction
of apartment buildings.
They even visit the Philharmonic,
which is not far from that drama theater
which was bombed by Russia
almost a year ago
to the day in what is believed to be
the biggest, perhaps mass casualty
event of this war
that you see him
sitting in the Philharmonic,
the deputy prime minister also noted
that they expect
to have a performance
at the drama theater as soon as April.
So very much touting their reconstruction
efforts here
because they've been doing
this kind of normalization
with Crimea since 2014.
So I think that's the message
they're trying to get across.
But of course, Ukraine
is making it very clear
that any kind of negotiation with
Russia will have to involve the return
of these territories,
something that Russia is clearly
taking off the table.
All right.
Thanks so much.
Claire Sebastian in London.
Appreciate it.
Now for more on this, I'm joined in Kiev
by international human rights lawyer
Wayne Jordache.
Thanks so much for being here with us.
So I want to just start
by getting your reaction
to what we were just talking about there.
A day
after the ICC issues an arrest warrant
for Putin, Putin shows up in Mariupol
a site of many
alleged war crimes by Russia.
Yes.
I mean that obviously,
as your previous speaker just said,
some kind of act of defiance,
but a rather empty gesture.
In the end,
the arrest warrants,
which he arrest warrant
he now
faces, will severely restrict
his movement internationally.
So heading to Russian occupied territory,
which belongs to Ukraine,
may be an act of defiance.
But as I say,
it doesn't speak to the
bigger problem he now faces.
All right.
So as a
international human
rights lawyer,
you have a lot of experience
dealing with the International
Criminal Court.
So how do they make the case
against Putin?
What kind of evidence will
they be relying on here?
Well, for this particular narrow
set of charges,
which relates
to the deportation of children
from Russian occupied territory
into Russia,
the evidence
really consists
of two or three main points.
Firstly, his public appearances, where he
clearly accepts
along with the commissioner for Human
for Children's
Rights, who's
also subject to an arrest warrant,
that they are involved in a scheme
of so-called adoption.
So there's the public admissions
from Putin.
Secondly, there's a presidential decree
which again implicates Putin
and the government in relation
to these adoptions.
And then, of course,
there's the evidence from the ground
that is
thousands of children
going missing
from Russian occupied territory,
many of them with children with parents
and disappearing into Russia.
So it's the scheme plus the admission
And I'd also say this
Putin is
subject to
an arrest warrant
on the basis of superior responsibility,
which basically means
that he has not prevented
those crimes or punished them.
And that's
why his admissions
publicly are so important,
is essentially approving of these crimes
when he's
giving these public comments
and therefore admitting to failing
to exercise
his superior responsibility,
which is a really serious issue.
Yeah.
And you were speaking about sort of
those narrow charges,
but obviously there's going to be
many more.
Your organization has experience
with these
mobile justice teams to collect evidence
in cases like these.
So what's involved with that
and what kind of challenges
do you and other investigators face?
Well, our mobile justice
teams are essentially
a support structure for the prosecution
at the moment.
There are hundreds of prosecutors
and thousands of police officers
and hundreds of state
security officers
from Ukraine in the field
gathering evidence.
And it's a really difficult task.
No one,
because the volume of crimes
is absolutely overwhelming.
Russia's tactics
essentially focus on attacking civilians.
So that gives rise
to literally thousands
of potential crimes.
Every time an area is liberated, mass
graves are recovered,
detention facilities are recovered.
There's forcible displacement,
this theft of children and so on
and so forth.
So it's a very difficult job
on the ground
to actually collect evidence
and that's the first phase
that essentially builds
a picture of who did what on the ground.
The next phase
is the most difficult phase,
and that's building up
the chain of command.
Who ordered those crimes,
who facilitated them,
who planned them, who designed them,
who controls them? And that
tracking up the chain
of command is how you implicate people.
Politicians such as Putin
And, you know, so
you're saying
that the volume of the material
is is daunting.
But also when it comes to the
the digital evidence,
sifting through all of it
and especially determining
what's real
and what isn't,
that must be a huge challenge as well.
Well, this
this is undoubtedly the most documented
crime base or conflict
the world has ever seen.
There are literally thousands
of organizations
documenting these crimes.
And, of course,
there's a whole prosecution
and judicial apparatus here
documenting these crimes.
And, of course,
we live in the digital age.
So everything is photographed,
everything appears on video.
There's Open-Source
experts such as Bellingcat
and so on, collecting evidence.
So it's a really daunting collection.
Of evidence.
We're talking about hundreds
of thousands of videos,
hundreds of thousands of photographs
and so on and so forth.
So trying to sift through
that is going to be the challenge.
Much of that,
regrettably, will not be that useful
in a courtroom.
You're a mature investigator.
Is can be extremely crucial
to an investigation,
but much of what they collect
can also
be collected in a way
which is just not admissible
in a trial process.
You can't verify the video,
you can't authenticate photograph.
You just cannot understand its relevance,
which probative value.
So it's a really it's a
it's a great thing
to have
all this documentation,
but it's also a real problem
in terms of being able to sift through it
and build a case,
a coherent and robust case.